1666 louis xiv inaugure les premières
grandes zones de versailles sous le
regard de son jardinier andré le nôtre
et de sa cour
trois cent cinquante ans plus tard les
cinquante cinq bassins et fontaines et
six enjeux de fond toujours la fierté de
la cité royale
chaque printemps les quinze bosquet
s'ouvre au public 72 représentations
musicales sont programmés dans les
jardins de ce vendredi 25 mars jusqu'à
la fin octobre
pour moi c'est un spectacle à part
entière qui en plus nous permet de
découvrir les bosquets comme vous le
savez les bosquets sont autant de
petites pièces dans les jardins de
versailles comme des salons de verdure
que l'on peut découvrir grâce à ses
grandes zones et on peut aussi admirer
ces fontaines qui sont toutes
différentes
donc on a le mélange des genres très
cher à versailles les sculptures les
eaux le dessin des jardins de chant des
grandes eaux musicales provient
également du mécanisme des fontaines les
35 km de canalisations hydrauliques sont
restées inchangées les méthodes pour les
actionner date également du xviie siècle
la préoccupation principale des gens
c'est de savoir comment ça fonctionne
parce que les gens pensent que tout
fonctionne avec des pompes donc à ça on
dément complètement c'est encore le
système comme sous l'époque du roi
c'est un système gravitaire n'y a pas du
tout de pompes qui font fonctionner les
fontaines les grandes eaux musicales de
versailles attire entre 10000 et 12000
visiteurs par jour